so if this is what I'm expanding I would
say that this is equal to the sum of do
you remember similar tation do you
remember that okay so let me remind you
of see meditation see meditation the
Greek letter Sigma is just equivalent to
the English letter s so it stands for
sum so you're adding up it's a shorthand
way to write up you're adding a bunch of
things okay so if for instance I that's
a bad example okay if I wanted you to
add up the first five even numbers okay
five even numbers is not too bad but if
I wanted you to add the first 50 even
numbers I really don't stand here and
write these all out so what I can do is
I could write it in this shorthand
notation I can say that this is the sum
of now every one of these terms right is
an even number so I can write them all
in kind of a same fashion they're all
two times something two times something
two times something to tow something so
I'll write this as two M right these are
the objects that I'm adding up which
one's am i adding up well the first end
will be this will be 2 times 1 right and
then this will be 2 times 2 2 times 3
you notice it goes up up by one every
time so I start from one and the last
one I'm going to get 2 will be 2 times
50 so I go from 1 all the way to 50 okay
so this is the Sigma notation way of
writing yes if I wanted to start at a
different point like say for example
maybe not the first 50 um even numbers
but maybe I want to start at 8 for some
reason because I'm weird like that okay
if I wanted to do that that's cool yeah
I have all of the terms are still 2
times something 2 times something but
instead of starting at N equals 1 I'm
gonna start at N equals 4 correct
so from starting from here and going to
there these are the things I'll add up
now this is exactly the same
this is 11 terms
that's a bit cruel to ask you to do the
answer does do it 11 is physically
possible if it were a hundred it would
not be physically possible but I'm
interested in writing it faster because
remember I'm looking at the clock in
fact by now my 60 seconds is already
finished right but I can write this
faster in this way every term that I get
out of this just like my terms of the
even numbers every time will look
somewhat similar right there's going to
be a binomial coefficient so there will
be like an NCR type thing so I'll just
write that and we'll put in some numbers
here in a minute then there's going to
be some number of these some number of
them and then there will be some number
of these I should leave a bit more of a
gap actually the question is how many do
I have no yet okay so if I started to
actually do this and it might help if
you're like I I'm not familiar with
doing these I need some practice but I
actually helped just to write the first
couple and then you can form this
general term quite easily so for example
the very very first term is going to be
10 choose 0
we always start from 0 with my nails so
10 choose 0 what will the next term be
well there will be 10 of these that's
the most you can get so how many of
these will we get 10 of them if there
are 10 of this one there will be none of
this one okay so that we exit have 0 ok
so that will be the first term and then
I'll move on to the next one the next
one will be term c1 I will have one less
of these and one more of these so it'll
look like this one less one and it will
keep going all the way 10 9 8 these will
eventually become 0 and then
whoopsie-daisy
these ones will become 10 that make
sense so I found I've got a rough idea
in my head now of what this thing is
going to be every single one of the
binomials will be 10 see something 10
see something 10 see something so we
usually called this guy okay
how many of these will I have well we
started with 10 and then we count down
okay so that would be 10 minus whatever
you've got okay
because for the the first term we count
our will be zero so 10 minus 0 is 10 and
then lastly over here see how these guys
count up right so they have R of them so
this this guy here is what we call the
general term because we haven't dealt
with a binomial theorem for a while baby
you haven't thought about these guys for
a little bit but that's the idea now I'm
not quite finished I know what each of
the terms looks like but I don't know
how many of them I have which ones right
so the number that is changing
constantly is our the very first R that
I'm gonna try out will be R equals 0 ok
what will be the last r that I try out
10 the last one dot will be 10 see 10 x
squared there won't be any of those guys
by then and all of these guys will take
over like so okay so in a pinch what
I've done is obviously this is much
faster than writing out in the eleven
terms and this also I mean this
demonstrates understanding I would say
that this demonstrates a very similar
level of understanding to just writing
out all 11 terms if not maybe a bit more
okay so at this point I would say okay
this guy is let's call this therefore
the nth term just a single term will be
this I'm not adding up all of the terms
anymore I'm just looking at a single one
of them now and the way you can tell is
that see there's no Sigma at the front
so this is equal to the sum of all these
things but the general term is just is
just one of them okay a lot of people
they mix this up they don't put this
imitation here which is incorrect this
is not equal to 100 with equal to 11
terms so that's why I have the Sigma Nu
if it goes all the way from 0 to 10
there's 11 terms in total which is the
middle term now if I'm counting up right
excuse me if I'm counting up this should
sorry about that if I count first second
third all the way to eleventh okay then
the middle one will be the sixth but
don't forget in binomial we actually
count from zero right we count from zero
so this will be 0 1 2 . up to 10
everything is one less you see that
so therefore the sixth term has R equal
to what value of 5
that's tricky isn't it ok so the middle
term is the sixth term where R is equal
to 5
so now I can say the middle term is term
5 which equals 10 see 5 x squared to the
5 minus 1 over 2 X to the 5 that's one
of the ways you can know you got the
middle term success and then is is the
question like what's the coefficient or
you just expand the thing just the whole
thing yeah so do you want me to do that
with you
it's yeah okay because he is just index
laws do watch out that negative sign is
a bit of a culprit a lot of people
forget that and because there's five of
them which is quite intentional by the
way because it's five of them you'll
still get a negative sign at the end so
yeah since there's five negative signs
hiding in there four of them will cancel
leaving one behind okay